in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
Victoria is with us hey Victoria how are
you hey Dave I'm good how are you better
than I deserve welcome good to have you
where do you live
I am from Madison Wisconsin very cool
welcome to Nashville and here to do your
debt-free screaming person I am what
made you decide to come all the way to
Nashville to do that well in May of 2014
I had graduated from college and had got
myself into a lot of student debt
student loan debt and I wanted to come
down here because I'm extremely proud of
the debt that I've paid off and you know
the goals that I've put together and I'm
just excited to be here and I wanted to
share with everyone what I've done it's
an excuse to come to Nashville Tennessee
salutely okay so how much have you paid
off I paid off $65,000 way to go awesome
and how long did that take you 18 months
whoa and your range of income during
that time I started out at 70,000 and
ended at just a little over a hundred
thousand way to go and what do you do
for a living I am in sales for a
pharmaceutical distribution company good
for you good for you great job great
income earning potential a lot of hard
work a lot of travel but you are you're
killing it huh yeah I'm doing well good
for you yeah that's that's really good
coming out the gate I mean most of them
most of you guys make up over 100 but
usually takes a little longer than that
so you're obviously a rock star very
well done
so what you came out of school and this
says I'm gonna attack the dad but what
made you believe you could and should
because most people don't do that so why
did you do it yeah so a couple months
after I graduated I sat down and I saw
how much I owed and it was extremely
stressful you know I felt like there was
a burden on me and I wanted to get ahead
in life I saw where my career was going
I saw my my income and I felt like all
of that money was being put away towards
towards debt and so I was like let's get
aggressive with this so that I can then
turn that money around once I'm done
paying off the debt and put it towards
retirement and put it towards a
for a house and my future yeah very
smart very smart and how did you get
connected to us so it was kind of funny
my boyfriend who is with me today here
has been a huge encouragement and
support system through all of this and
he knew I had a lot of dud after school
and had said hey have you heard a Dave
Ramsey and I said you know that's funny
actually I do know who Dave Ramsey is
I'm pretty sure we have the book at home
sitting on the shelf so I I wiped off
the dust and we opened it up and he read
it first and then I read it and we sat
down and we put together a budget for
for me ah a dusty old Total Money
Makeover book got it all started okay
yes very cool good for you guys very
very well done this is awesome yeah very
cool
okay so somebody's listening just coming
out of school and they sat down and for
some reason it just occurred to them
that they've got $65,000 worth of debt
and they have that gulp moment you
remember when the sweat is on your lip
or lip and in your hands and you're like
oh my god yeah tell them what the secret
is that caused you to be able to do this
in 18 months what's the secret to
getting out of debt I think there's a
few secrets
the first one is self discipline you
know being able to say no to things that
you want was the biggest thing you
should know to social activities I'm
going to dinner with friends um you know
if I go shopping with my girlfriends you
know still being able to go but not
buying anything so I think those are the
biggest things the second secret I would
say is is the budget that's where it all
starts and knowing exactly where every
dollar is going that's coming into your
bank account every two weeks and then
the third thing is is I was a big
advocate of the cash envelopes um so I
had a week 1 week 2 week 3 and week 4
and I'd take out all my cash you know
either on the first of the 15 for that
next month know so that when I went to
the grocery store if I spent $20 on
groceries and I had 100 for the week I
knew I had $80 left because it's just so
easy to swipe a card nowadays um and
that's where you're really getting a lot
of trouble so
the envelope system really gave you just
a sense of power over yeah and I suppose
use it today yeah you know if anything
is we've been doing this for
20-something here's my wife Sharon still
carries envelope system in her purse
still uses it to this day because of the
same thing it's it's permission to spend
as rachel says because if you look in
there and there's money in the clothing
envelope you can buy some clothing and
not feel guilty or not feel like you
busted your budget or you were
irresponsible or something but if
there's no money in there then you can't
buy it that's it I mean it's just a real
simple yes or no that you gave to
yourself and there's either money in
there or there's not that that's very
smart very cool Victoria way to go I'm
proud of you you're a hero took control
of your life so what are you twenty-five
twenty-six I am 25 okay very good
excellent job very fun very well done
oh man and killing it on the income man
this is awesome you got just a huge
potential ahead of you really really
good stuff well we're going to give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired number one bestseller show you
how to take the next step what the next
chapter is in Victoria's book and that's
build wealth and be an outrageously
generous person because you're going to
be in a position to do both very well
done good for you thanks Dave all right
Victoria Madison Wisconsin $65,000 paid
off in 18 months making 70 all the way
up to a hundred thousand count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one I'm free
way to go way to go awesome that's how
you do it right there well done well
done
and that's fabulous good for you hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar intercom